the mainstream media is lying to you
silencing my First Amendment right to
get clicks human-animal chimeras with no
right
I'm Jordan Klepper and we are the
opposition subscribe to my youtube
channel the opposition it's your fault
coffee machines are everywhere it's then
a giant web of Clinton scandals and
corruption the moon all of these
devious things that happen in the world
ties back only to one place and one
place only right here you have a choice
surrender to the establishment or oppose
Oh
if truck is a moron then I'm a
law don't trust anybody who's
talking to a camera I should know I'm
pro-life myself all connected
[Applause]
click on the subscribe button wherever
[Music]